make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and we're bringing back how to kill
superheroes let me you know if anybody
cares anymore right like I have no idea
of this videos gonna get uploaded and
then people are just gonna be like don't
care and it'll get like no viewers I
have no clue there's only one way to
find out now in this video we are going
to discuss how to kill the super villain
black hand but technically the
information that we're going to cover
here could more broadly be applied to
killing any member of the Black Lantern
Corps so this is why it's called black
hand a Black Lantern Corps now the first
thing we're going to briefly discuss is
black hand but we'll also need to
broaden our discussion to explain
exactly what the Black Lantern Corps is
as well before we discuss getting into
how to kill black hand
so black hand made his first appearance
in green lantern number 29 in 1964 but
his origin was actually updated after
Infinite Crisis in 2005 which has been
the basis of his character that's
appeared in modern-day comics and this
is the version that we're gonna be
discussing in this video now this
version of black hand is actually named
William Han and his parents are
coroner's in a funeral director so he
develops an obsession with death and
dead bodies at a very early age that
would be a huge factor in eventually
driving him toward a life of crime later
Han finds himself being sought out by
Atrocitus leader of the Red Lanterns
because he has foreseen that hand
possesses what he calls the power of the
block which Atrocitus believes will lead
to the demise of the guardians of the
universe
now Atrocitus builds a cosmic divining
rod to kill hand by duranium of his
energy but hand is saved when Hal Jordan
Sinestro show up to stop Atrocitus which
allows Han to gain possession of the
divining rod himself and then escape
following this hand adopts the
supervillain moniker at the black hand
and during the blackest night storyline
would begin to see an increase in his
power level and will begin seeing
visions of the black power battery on a
dead planet called Ryu I'm pretty sure
it's collar that could be wrong these
visions lead him to roam the desert and
he begins hearing voices telling him to
reclaim souls that have been lost to the
person speaking and eventually he
returns to his family's house and kills
his parents and his siblings and then
commits suicide it's pretty dark he's
then visited by one of the guardians of
the universe named scar who produces the
first black power ring initially by
vomiting it up like I'm 100% serious
that's exactly what happens I'm not even
making that up
this reanimates black hand and scar
gives him the ring this not only
effectively makes him the first black
Lantern but scar says the black hand is
now the physical embodiment of death
itself much in the same way that
parallax is the embodiment of fear or
ion is the embodiment of willpower
so this is the point in the video where
we would typically talk about the powers
of the character that were
discussing and that's pretty much what
we're gonna be doing here but we're
technically talking about the powers and
the abilities granted by the Black
Lantern ring because black hand doesn't
actually have any powers on his own
since he's just a normal guy that found
and stole a cosmic energy draining
weapon so as you guys probably know the
various colored rings and the Green
Lantern mythos draw their power from a
different emotion on the emotional
spectrum of light Green Lantern's are
powered by willpower blue lanterns are
powered by hope red lanterns are powered
by rage and so on the black lanterns are
a little bit different as they are
actually not powered by an emotion but
by death itself for that reason the only
ones who can wield the Black Power rings
are those that have already died and
like we discussed earlier with black
hand they're reanimated upon receiving
the ring now in addition to the
abilities common to the power rings of
any color such as allowing users to fly
and create hard light constructs the
black power ring confers its wielder
abilities that are unique to it the
primary ability of the Black Lantern
ring is the reanimation of corpses which
is really the main function of the Black
Lantern Corps itself once the corpses
are reanimated any damage they sustained
even the loss of limbs can be undone by
the power ring so in terms of being hard
to kill black Lantern's pose the
difficulty of not only being able to
raise an army of the dead to protect
them but also regenerate any injuries
they sustained not to mention the fact
that technically black Lantern's are
already dead so our job isn't really so
much as killing them as it is ending the
reanimation that the power ring provides
furthermore the wielder of the Black
Lantern ring is able to read the emotion
of anyone they encounter in terms of the
color on the emotional spectrum that
they most personify so for instance if a
black lantern encountered Hal Jordan
they would read his aura as being green
because he most personifies willpower
this might not seem like very much of a
consequence and it doesn't really make
them harder to kill but it might
actually give us a possible way to
exploit a weakness of the Black Lantern
ring part of this ability is that there
are certain individuals of the ring
cannot detect because they don't have
normal emotions this includes demonic
forces such as Ettrick in the demon
entities that are not technically
capable of human emotions like cyborgs
Superman and teenagers and those with an
unbalanced mental state such as
scarecrow all those individuals have
been able to go undetected by black
Lantern's as if they were invisible to
them so while this isn't going to kill a
Black Lantern on its own
it might make the task easier if we
enlist someone with a similar ability to
carry out our plan without being sensed
by the Black Lantern but believe it or
not there are actually a few ways of
black Lantern's including black hand can
be killed the first way is to simply
step
the ring from its where if the black
lantern loses the power ring it will
cease being a lantern at all and go back
to just being a corpse this can be
accomplished if the wielder of the Black
Lantern ring is forced to experience
emotion and the ring itself will
actually flee from its wearer this
actually happened when Superboy used an
artifact known as the Medusa mask to
cause two black Lantern's to feel the
full range of emotion in blackest night
Superman number three and as we saw in
teen titans number 78 the touch of
another black Lantern is also sufficient
to sever the bond between a black
Lantern ring and its wearer the same
result can be achieved if the power ring
is broken which would presumably be done
by anyone able to exert enough strength
but the amount of strength it would
actually take would pretty much be
insane now it's also possible to simply
destroy the corpse at any rate faster
than the ring is able to regenerate it
this has been done by the corrosive
vomit produced by Red Lanterns that
basically dissolves those it touches and
could also presumably be done by any
force capable of disintegrating the body
of a black lantern as it would be an
instantaneous destruction of the corpse
and wouldn't allow any time for
restoration and finally there are
multiple forces within the DC Universe
capable of destroying a black lantern
including black hand first the white
lantern rings or the combined force of a
Green Lantern ring with any other ring
color can weaken a black lantern perhaps
to the point of destroying them and
light-based heroes such as dr. light
halo and Dove have also been shown to be
able to destroy black Lantern's so
despite the fact that black Han and the
black Lantern's are indeed powerful and
capable of a great deal of destruction
there are several ways to kill them that
we've proven to be effective I think I
got most of them if not all of them here
but if there is anything that I've
forgotten then let me know in the
comments but without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments explain
and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace